guck mal schon also halloween mäßig
eingerichtet mit der orangenen lampe und
so zu halloween ist jetzt auch nicht
allerdings ist das heutige wieder ein
bisschen ja auch nicht halloween mäßig
eigentlich aber das einzige was heute
wirklich passend zu halloween online
gegangen ist ist der neue podcast von
samir einwickelt der beschreibung
halloween special mit luca und sandra
geil aller würde ich direkt mal nicht
draufklicken allerdings will ich sagen
für mich jetzt erstmal mit dem heutigen
video uns war dies bereits im titel
eingeblendet wir schauen uns heute fällt
marken an
die beispielsweise von oreo na dann
glaube ich jeder die kekse eine fake
marketing gefunden habe ist bo rio rio
jumbo edition sogar direkt weiter mit
der nächsten feldmark und zwar kennt ja
denke ich jeder von euch burger king
was denke ich allerdings nicht jeder von
euch kennt ist burger madame und ich
denke auch jeder von euch kennt hugo
boss aber sehr viele werden
wahrscheinlich nicht die marke buchhorst
aber gut freude machen direkt weiter mit
der nächsten fälligen marke uns verkennt
den jeder von euch adidas das t shirt
was hier gerade sogar auch von adidas da
gibt es allerdings noch eine andere
marke
die heißt es da dies sagen und ich meine
neben der klamotten mark ist sitzt da
haben wir natürlich auch noch police
station ja vor allem ist es halt auch
eine nintendo wii station also quasi
eine nintendo playstation superarbeit
ihr da geleistet haben ich frage mich
wirklich was ich diese leute dabei
denken wenn sie ihre läden benennen und
bisher aber wirklich das meist irgendwie
aus dem asiatischen raum wo er sehr viel
von der west- europäischen kultur et
cetera auch anscheinend dann ja auch
unternehmen jetzt einfach schlichtweg
kopiert werden allerdings ist das
nächste in spanien oder mexiko oder
irgendwo und zwar ist der laden einfach
master
das ist eigentlich das logo und der
halbe name von mastercard und das ist
ein kreditkartenunternehmen aber okay
ich mein mann denkt sich jetzt eventuell
das kann ja nicht noch schlimmer werden
als morio als die star von adidas und
als master wie von mastercard doch und
zwar verkauft hier jemand schuhe ja ich
glaube ich schon bleiben wir direkt bei
iphone beziehungsweise apple und zwar
einem unternehmen dass apple vor einiger
zeit aufgekauft hat und zwar beats by dr
dre
das ist ein unternehmen die kopfhörer
herstellen
davon gibt es allerdings eine fade marke
namens die zwei nani ja ich weiß nicht
was dies bedeutet und ich weiß auch
nicht wer nani ist ich kann nur den
ehemaligen fußballspieler nani aber ich
glaube nicht dass da jetzt plötzlich da
kopfhörer mit dietz gemacht hat werden
wir uns allerdings eine komplett andere
sparte und zwar in den kaffee sparte
falls das café staaten überhaupt gibt
ich glaube auf jeden fall dass jeder von
euch das unternehmen starbucks kennt
jeder von euch war schon mal bei
starbucks allerdings war glaube ich noch
nie jemand von euch bei sun bugs coffee
ist wieder irgend so ein laden in china
und was ein anderes chinesisches
unternehmen gemacht hat ist sie haben
sich die boxershorts von calvin klein
angeschaut habe sich gedacht kopieren
die einfach 11 wir schreiben allerdings
nicht calvin klein drauf sondern klein
klein und ich weiß nicht was deren
mission damit war allerdings wieder
weiter mit einem klamotten unternehmen
beziehungsweise einem unternehmen das
auch auf schuhe einen großen fokus liegt
und zwar nike beziehungsweise kein und
auch hier ja ich schreibe ja es ist ja
ihr seht auch hier was hier falsch ist
und com leute wo wir direkt hier bei
nike sind und vorhin auch schon einmal
adidas hatte nämlich habe doch einen
weiteren adidas fake sitz und anstand
drei streifen um die elf auf vier
streifen
ja aber wenn ihr keinen bock haben
solltet auf mike oder absatz oder absatz
ist oder wie die adidas da hießen dann
gibt es auch noch parat hab ich kann
ja auch nicht erklären dem
unternehmenslogo das jetzt ähnlich sieht
du dass ich ähnlich anhört jedoch kommen
wir nur wieder zu einer komplett neuen
kategorie rundfahrt zur sonnencreme und
da denkt man sich vielleicht hey haben
jetzt vielleicht nie wer irgendwie
niveau angeschrieben oder sohn ein die
aber warum ihre sonnencremen das logo
des internet explorers draufgepackt
andré wie kommt man denn auf sonne
scheiße wo wir allerdings kann bei
scheiße sind dass sie ist ein rucksack
und auf dem steht einfach harry potter
obendrauf links steht obama und dann ist
da noch sonnig abgebildet also ich weiß
nicht was das jetzt sein soll hey ich
bin harry potter fan und dein
lieblingsspiel ist sonnig und ich habe
obama gewählt also den rucksack der ist
genau das passende für mich das hier ist
die nächste marke um die es geht uns war
seht ihr hier schon das richtige
unternehmen eingeblendet kitkat junkie
keine ahnung was junkie da jetzt genau
ist ich kann nur das normale kitkat aber
in einem anderen land heißt das ganze
kicker superklasse eure kreativität da
rein weil doch direkt beim ersten meine
lieben freunde und zwar kennt glaube ich
jeder von euch pizza hut das ist eine
franchise kette unternehmen die pizza
herstellen
ich selbst mag die pizza nicht so gern
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen ich stehe
auf pizza mit dünnem boden italienisch
groß dies das allerdings geht es ja hier
nicht um einen pizza geschmack luca ps3
kommt ja bald schon in die läden
das ist ja dann der geschmacksexplosion
schlechthin genau sondern es geht ja
heute und fake marken und zwar in diesem
fall und pizza hut taco
ja auch an der stelle wirklich hab mal
gemacht und das hier ist die erste fake
marke muss glaube ich nichts zu sagen
ist ein foto mit dem screen eines
iphones und das unternehmen hat auch
nicht nokia sondern no klar klar googles
ja
was auch immer googles sein sollen
allerdings meine damen und herren ich
glaube ich hatte noch nicht genug mit
den ganzen nike und adidas sales bei bay
ich habe hier noch ein nike fail
beziehungsweise einen fake marke für
euch ja da wird nicht nur der name
verändert sondern auch der schweiz ist
ein wenig anders geworden allerdings
habe ich für euch noch ein weiteres
unternehmen das hier bearbeitet wurde
und zwar hier könnte man die kommentare
schreiben was das eigentlich für einen
klamotten unternehmen ist was allerdings
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten
unternehmen das hier gefällt wurde und
zwar ist es dass hier das hört sich auf
den ersten moment gar nicht mal so
falsch an
wenn man dann allerdings nicht das ganze
mal vor liest und hört deutsche banana
dann ist da doch ein ordentlicher fake
das unternehmen ist allerdings wieder
eine fastfoodkette und zwar kfg ja weil
ich als kentucky fried chicken wir
setzen kentucky fried gegeben
genau die nächste fake marke setzt bei
der it branche an
also ja ich versuche da immer so ein
bisschen was zu sagen zu den fake marken
aber schaut einfach selbst was soll ich
da sagen
microsoft bin muss ich meine sie am
arsch ist denn die person die sich denkt
ja so nehme ich mein unternehmen und wo
wir auch gerade schon bei microsoft bzw
michaels oft sind was sollen dass ihr
dass er das ist das google logo bzw der
schriftzug beziehungsweise der name auf
toilettenpapier erwischte dir deinen
arsch mit google hat es teure mission
oder auch das hier so ich tags einfach
nicht auf den ersten blick klar sie
vernünftig aus aber es ist keine
playstation oder in einem pop station
oder auch hier das sind kurz die
kulissen eigentlich cross oder auch hier
wir hatten wohl schon pippan stadtplan
jetzt haben wir auch noch nie war also
ich meine leute mehr als klatschen kann
ich da wirklich nicht tun kommen
allerdings schon zur vorletzten fake
marke die ich wollte raus zu haben und
zwar ist es nicht red bull sondern red
bull und es ist auch kein energy drink
sondern ein food drink und kommen wir
jetzt auch
meine damen und herren zuletzt nicht
richtigen feldmarker also sind die
echten marken mit den echten logos und
so weiter und so fort allerdings ihr
könnt mir ja gerne sagen was die hier
versuchen zu machen aber schaut euch
erstmal an
da ist der place tor also der google
places dann google daneben und whatsapp
und die verkaufen einfach klamotten und
haben sich einfach ist haben sich ein
fairplay store google trotzt genannt
warum seid ihr da auf der anderen seite
der welt so krank am arsch an der stelle
mich dass heute wird jetzt allerdings
auch beenden meine lieben freunde werde
ich meine wegschaut diese kuriosesten
fake marken gefallen hat das unternehmen
einen daumen hoch unter dem video hier
da würde mich wirklich mega mega drive
freuen ich habe noch so viele weitere
feldmark wunder also wenn ihr einen
zweiten teil hiervon haben wollt
schreibt es auf jeden fall gerne und in
die kommentare und abonniert main kanal
unter dem video
falls sie keine videos mehr verpassen
wollt ich sehe mir das 50% die meine
videos wirklich schauen sind kein
abonnent von meinem kanal also ich weiß
nicht wie ihr dann auf meine videos
kommt ihr werdet aber die suche oder
keine ahnung was aber abonniert doch
einfach und wenn ich schon aber das sagt
klingt doch gern auf die glocke dann
bekommt er eine benachrichtigung sobald
ich ein neues video hochladen
ja was kann ich noch sagen neue podcast
rausgekommen heute also genau jetzt
gerade sondern ich mache eine halloween
special wir reden über grausige
geschichten und lachen ganz ganz viel
weil wir uns irgendwie selbst nicht
ernst nehmen können was noch passiert
auch senders kanal ist ein neues video
online gekommen ich hatte heute morgen
einen supertollen schiffe
[Musik]